so as of of mid or so April of 2023 he
said in that hearing 650 cases roughly
half you know essentially weren't uh
identified so are we on the same path to
what we were uh are these contradictions
relevant I say yes especially for the
history of this but I say yes and is
there disinformation coming from all
angles and I think that those are
important questions with evidence to
back it up that that we need to be
asking right now because we don't have
the answers and and one last final
thought and I pointed this on on my uh
YouTube channel myself is when you look
at Kirkpatrick talk he looks strained he
looks like he's forced to be there
thank you chairwoman Jewel brand uh
ranking member Ernst distinguished
members of the subcommittee
it's a privilege to be here today to
testify on the defense uh defense's
efforts to address unidentified
anomalous phenomena
first I want to thank Congress for its
extensive and continued partnership as
the department works to better
understand and respond to UAP in an
effort to minimize Technical and
intelligence surprise and he looks like
he's forced to say what he is that's an
opinion let me stress that based on
nothing but an opinion but when you look
at Dr J Alan heineck who happened to
have been the main scientific uh advisor
and consultant and scientist on The
Project Blue Book UFO investigations
through the 50s and 60s when you look at
his evolution
he was essentially made to explain UFOs
we know that because he later wrote
books about it there's there was a shift
while he was working with the government
that he had seen enough to realize the
government was not taking it seriously
that he was forced to explain the
objects but a lot of objects could not
be explained and he went from that
skeptic to believer after he left the
U.S Air Force in Project Blue Book
closed he started his own UFO research
organization and went on for years
investigating UFOs and and those with
what they call physical trace evidence I
spent a lot of time with his Protege uh
the late Ted Phillips who sadly passed
away a few years but I had produced and
wrote some History Channel shows that
profiled Dr heineck and Ted Phillips and
the amount of information that they went
out and collected uh brought it back and
and a lot of stuff that had you know
quite a few question marks about it not
proof of of aliens per se but rather
question marks that led to what were
these crafts coming down what altered
the soil why why were these physical
trace evidence left behind so on and so
forth so now again going to comparing
the the two eras Here Is Kirkpatrick
just brought in as that scientist to be
forced to explain and I don't know again
maybe he just doesn't like cameras and
doesn't like hearing settings and just
was a little nervous you know that's a
possibility but to me it screamed that
he was forced to read this is a lot of
what we have is all explainable and what
we don't uh they're signs of Russia and
China but I can't really go into it and
he went through those points
um but again I I think that there's more
to that story and I think that uh
hopefully in the years to come we'll
start really digging in and finding out
what that story is but I don't think the
whole story is written yet I really
don't and as much as the government
wants to now lean on the balloon angle
and essentially dismiss UAP uh in the
sense that they can explain it so
dismiss the the Intrigue the mystery a
little bit I don't think you can I
really don't
was there uh in the same way that with
Sean there's a discernible tonality and
Body Language shift maybe not shift well
for heinek was there a shift like you
said that he was this way before then
some way afterward did you see it from
how he was presenting himself for
conducting himself
times were a lot different in the 1950s
and 60s uh the film film reels are going
to be fairly limited obviously film is
round but uh they didn't record
everything like today but when you hear
heinek talk in some of the earlier Clips
because we went through a ton of stock
footage uh and by a ton I just mean like
every reel that we could find of Jay
Alan heineck and you can see a tone
difference between those earlier days
and his swamp gas you know he was the
infamous swamp gas guy uh versus later
on to create a UFO organization to write
books about UFOs to go out and and
figure out or try to figure out what
scientific evidence and proof was there
to to collect and his main scope or I I
guess it's arguable if it was his main
scope but uh his his Protege and my my
friend Ted Phillips who had mentioned
earlier his main scope was the physical
trace evidence that stuff that that they
could put in front of you and say Kurt
here's the dirt from this from the
landing area here's the control sample
and here's the dirt uh analysis showing
that it was was called hydroponic I
think it is where it rejects water uh
when the control uh sample does not I
think it was called Hydro hydroponic
Hydro gosh now I'm drawing a blank on it
it's been quite a few years the science
was a little over my head but
essentially it wouldn't uh uh wouldn't
suck in the water like and make mud that
the the the soil was changed uh to to a
point of of not being able to get the
water so he was able to show you that
type of of stuff and that's science and
that all stemmed from Jay Allen heineck
and and his vision after he left Project
Blue Book so there was absolutely a
difference in tone from the early days
to his latter days you just watched a
clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy